WHY DON'T TOP FBI AND DOJ
>>> THE AUTHOR OF VENGEANCE,
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
NEWT GINGRICH IS WITH US.
THEY DIDN'T WANT THE INFORMATION
RE
R
RELEASED IN THE BEGINNING AND
THIS IS POWERFUL FROM THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE CHAIR.
HE'S BASICALLY CONFIRMING WHAT I
FOR DOSSIER WAS USED IN PART
DURING THE ELECTION SEASON TO
GET A FISA WARRANT TO SPY ON THE
MEAN TO YOU?
THE FIRST IS IT TURNS OUT THERE
MAY HAVE BEEN COLLUSION TO
UNDERMINE THE AMERICAN
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION BY A
WASN'T RUSSIAN, IT WAS AMERICAN
AND THAT IT WAS THE DEPARTMENT
NOW THAT ON ONE LEVEL IS A
FRIGHTENING INSIDE OF THE FUTURE
AND THE FUTURE OF A POWERFUL
POLICE FORCE DECIDING FOR THE
REST OF US WHICH POLITICIANS
WILL GO AFTER.
AND THE SECOND THING AS YOU WERE
TALKING IS THERE'S A NEW MOVIE
OUT WHICH GLORIFIES THE
WASHINGTON POST AND PRINTING OF
GOVERNMENT DOCUMENTS, THE
COURAGE OF THE POST LEADERSHIP.
YOU GO BACK AND TAKE THE
PENTAGON PAPERS AND THE ATTITUDE
ARE COMING IN AND MAKING THE
SAME DEMANDS.
OF COURSE WE SHOULD PUBLISH THIS
AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SHOULD
SEE IT AND THERE'S A RIGHT TO
KNOW.
>> Sean: MAYBE IT'S HANNITY AND
COMPANY TO FILE THE LAWSUIT.
THERE'S A DANGEROUS THING HERE
AND I'M MAKE STRONG DISTINCTION
BECAUSE I HAVE RESPECT FOR THE
INTELLIGENCE WE NOW HAVE TO GET
ISIS AND al-QAEDA AND ENEMIES OF
THE COUNTRY, IF WE TURN IT AND
POLITICIZE IT AND SPY ON
OPPOSITION PARTY CANDIDATES AND
USE THAT WE HAVE LOST THE
COUNTRY.
BACK TO AT LEAST 1970s OF PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT GENUINELY WORRIED AN
INTELLIGENCE STATE DURING THE
COLD WAR WOULD ACQUIRE SO MUCH
POWER IT COULD ACTUALLY SUBVERT
THE WHOLE PROCESS.
IT'S SAD THAT ALMOST NONE OF
THOSE PEOPLE ARE NOW SPEAKING
OUT ABOUT THE CURRENT PROBLEM
THIS IS ALL A THIN LAYER OF
LARGELY POLITICALLY APPOINTED
ENFORCE THE LAW, BUT THIS THIN
LAYER I THINK WE'LL DISCOVER IN
ORDER TO GET AN ABILITY TO SPY
WHICH WAS TOTALLY ILLEGAL.
I THINK THAT'S PART OF WHY YOU
SAW McCABE LEAVE.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE MORE PEOPLE
LEAVE.
I'M SHOCKED STRZOK IS STILL
THERE.
AFTER ALL THE STUFF WE LEARN
ABOUT HIM I DON'T KNOW WHY HE'S
NOT GONE ALREADY.
I THINK YOU'LL SEE MORE PEOPLE
HAVE TO LEAVE AND THEN SEE
WHETHER OR NOT IN FACT THEY GET
INVOLVED IN A SERIOUS CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION BECAUSE A LOT OF
WHAT THEY WERE DOING WAS NOT
JUST UNWISE BUT ILLEGAL AND THEY
WERE REALLY THREATENING THE
FREEDOM AND RIGHTS OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW WHAT'S AMAZING
ABOUT THIS IS THIS DOSSIER,
HILLARY CLINTON NEVER VERIFIED
IT AND THEY TRIED TO SHOP THE
SALACIOUS STORY OF HOOKERS AND
RITZ CARLTON AND THEY WERE
SHOPPING IT AND COORDINATING
WITH THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
HILLARY CLINTON CLEARLY FIXED
THE PRIMARY.
SHE TRIED TO USE THE DOSSIER TO
LIE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN A
GENERAL.
THATS DO
THATS D
THATS DO DOSSIER WAS WAS USED
AGAINST A CANDIDATE AND A YEAR
OF TRUMP/RUSSIA COLLUSION AND
THE MEDIA HAS IGNORED THE
BIGGEST STORY IN THEIR LIFE
TIME.
THIS IS BIGGER THAN WATERGATE.
IT'S LIKE STEIG
IT'S LIKE STEI
IT'S LIKE STEAL
IT'S LIKE STEALIN
IT'S LIKE STEALING
IT'S LIKE STEALING A
IT'S LIKE STEALING A S
IT'S LIKE STEALING A SNI
IT'S LIKE STEALING A SNICK
IT'S LIKE STEALING A SNICKER
IT'S LIKE STEALING A SNICKERS
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING WITH
THIS.
THE ELITE MEDIA GROUP HAS
SURVIVED BY BEING IN COAL  -- CO
THIS.
WHEN PEOPLE GET TO READ THIS,
WHAT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND IS THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION IN A SERIES OF
STEPS THAT CLEARLY VIOLATED THE
LAW TRIED TO BOTH PROTECT
HILLARY CLINTON AND TRIED TO
DESTROY DONALD TRUMP AND BOTH
ACTIONS WERE ILLEGAL.
WE'RE NOW IN A SITUATION, I
BELIEVE, WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO
SEE A REQUIREMENT IN THE NEAR
FUTURE FOR AN INDEPENDENT
COUNSEL TO CLEAN OUT THE SENIOR
FBI AND JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
TO GO AFTER PEOPLE WHO HAVE LEFT
OFFICE WHO WERE PART OF THE
OBAMA TEAM THAT WAS SO CLEARLY
VIOLATING THE LAW.
>> Sean: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
UNION INTEREST.
WE HAVE GREAT NEWS.
WE HAVE 2.4 MILLION NEW JOBS AND
NEWER PEOPLE THAT ARE ON FOOD
STAMPS.
THE PRESIDENT GIVES THIS GREAT
ECONOMIC SUCCESS.
PEOPLE ARE NOW BUILDING
MANUFACTURING AND TAXES ARE
DOWN.
AMERICANS ARE GETTING MORE MONEY
STARTING FEBRUARY 1 IN THEIRING
TO THE.
HE'S TRYING TO KEEP THE COUNTRY
SECURE.
YOU GET ONE REACTION THE NEWS
MEDIA AND ANOTHER REACTION WITH
A CBS AND CNN POLL THAT SHOWS
SOMETHING VERY DIFFERENT.
DISCONNECT?
>> I KEEP TELLING YOU, THE ELITE
MEDIA IN THE UNITED STATES IS
NOT NEUTRAL.
THEY'RE NOT REFEREES.
THEY'RE THE OFFENSIVE WING OF
THE OTHER TEAM.
THE ELITE MEDIA -- AND YOU SAW
SOME OF THIS IN THE CLIPS YOU
OU
OUTRAGEOUS BIZARRE AND
ANTI-TRUMP.
THEY'RE FULLY AS MUCH AS PART OF
THE OPPOSITION AS IS NANCY
PELOSI OR CHUCK SCHUMER AND WHY
YOU'RE GETTING THIS UNBELIEVABLY
BIASSED COVERAGE.
I MUST SAY WHEN I WATCHED LAST
NIGHT AND SAW THE PRESIDENT SAY
WE HAVE THE LOWEST BLACK
UNEMPLOYMENT IN HISTORY AND
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, WHO ARE
THEY LOYAL TO?
REALLY DRAMATICALLY HELP THEIR
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICTS WHO DO
THEY REPRESENT?
I THINK IT'S A REAL CHALLENGE TO
THE LEFT WING ETHNIC LEADERSHIP